los negocios no le han salido bien acá
en days así que tendrá una venta de
liquidación este fin de semana tiene
actualmente
1900 pesos en bienes que consisten en
250 limpiadores de oídos y 175 cepillos
para la nariz escribe una ecuación para
representar el precio mínimo por un
limpiador de oídos en lo voy a utilizar
con esta variable con la variable m y
por un cepillo de la nariz por el precio
mínimo del cepillo de la nariz que lo
voy a poner con la letra n n mayúscula
que tendréis debe establecer para quedar
pareja sin pérdidas ni ganancias y bueno
pues aquí tenemos que poner la ecuación
ahora qué datos tenemos nosotros sabemos
que andéis tiene 250 limpiadores de
oídos por lo tanto voy a poner aquí mis
250 limpiadores de oídos ya éstos los
voy a multiplicar por lo que va a valer
cada uno de ellos y aquí dice que cada
uno de ellos tiene un precio mínimo de
por lo tanto voy a poner 250 que
multiplica que multiplica
ok ya esto tenemos que sumarle bueno
pues cuántos cepillos para la nariz
tiene a esto le voy a sumar
175 ok que es la cantidad de cepillos
para la nariz que tienen déjame ponerle
un poco de espacio aquí ok ya esto lo
tengo que multiplicar por el precio
mínimo de cada uno de los cepillos para
la nariz
voy a multiplicar esto por n ok
250 por m más 175 por n bueno pues es la
cantidad de dinero que ella tiene
invertida en limpiadores de oídos y
también en cepillos para la nariz pero
nosotros sabemos que esta cantidad es de
1900 pesos justo eso nos dice el
problema ella tiene actualmente 1900
pesos en bienes y por lo tanto esta
cantidad estos los vendía por completo
debe de ser igual debe ser igual
1900 que 1900 pensando en el precio
mínimo en que ella lo puede vender y
esto es para que ella no pierda más de
la cantidad que tienen bienes
actualmente si esto fuera menor que 1900
pues bueno entonces ella estaría
perdiendo dinero aunque ahora dice
un gran comerciante le ofrece a que
dense comprar todo su inventario a
precio de mayoreo equivalente a 4 pesos
por limpiador de oídos y 7 pesos por
cepillo de la nariz debería querer
aceptar esta oferta si no quiere tener
pérdidas y bueno para eso déjame traer
aquí mi libreta de apuntes para resolver
esta última pregunta y poder contestarla
justo aquí entonces déjame sacar mi
libreta de apuntes muy bien y vamos a
recordar qué es lo que teníamos hasta
ahorita nosotros ya habíamos obtenido la
ecuación que estaba escrita justo aquí
esta ecuación la habíamos obtenido
fijándonos en la cantidad de limpiadores
de oídos que teníamos que eran 250 ok
los voy a poner aquí
250 ya esto lo multiplicaba por el
precio mínimo por un limpiador de oídos
el precio mínimo era el ok el precio
mínimo no lo sabemos y si a esto le
sumamos ok la cantidad de cepillos para
la nariz que tenemos que es 175 ok a
esto lo voy a sumar 175 y lo voy a
multiplicar por el precio un mínimo que
cuesta cada uno de los cepillos para la
nariz que por cierto sn entonces déjame
ponerlo con este color por n esto tenía
que ser exactamente igual a la cantidad
de dineros que tenía que jens en bienes
que es
1900 y por lo tanto voy a decir que esto
es exactamente lo mismo que 1900 de tal
manera que esta ecuación representa el
precio mínimo al cual debe de vender sus
productos haters y bueno ahora lo que
quiero es ver si le conviene la oferta
que le está ofreciendo este comerciante
dice un gran comerciante le ofrece a que
hay de comprar todo su inventario a
precio de mayoreo equivalente a 4 pesos
por limpiador de vídeos y 7 pesos por
cepillo para la nariz debería querer
aceptar esta oferta si no quiere tener
pérdidas bueno si ella no quiere tener
pérdidas entonces lo que le tiene que
ofrecer
este gran comerciante debe de ser mayor
o igual que en 1900 pesos porque si es
algo menor que 1900 bueno pues en
definitiva no le conviene que dense y
para eso este comerciante les está
ofreciendo 4 pesos y déjame ponerlo con
este color le está ofreciendo 4 pesos
por cada limpiador de oídos mientras que
por otra parte les está ofreciendo 7
pesos por cada uno de sus cepillos para
la nariz por lo tanto qué te parece si
en esta ecuación sustituimos el precio
mínimo por un limpiador de oídos es
decir en por 4 ok y voy a sustituir 7
pesos por el precio mínimo para cada
cepillo de la nariz ok y entonces esto
quiero que sea mayor o igual que 1900 es
decir me va a quedar lo siguiente
250 que multiplica a él pero vamos a ver
si cumple que al menos es el precio
mínimo estos cuatro pesos por lo tanto
voy a multiplicarlo por 4 ok ya esto le
voy a sumar a esto le voy a sumar
175 175 ok que va a multiplicar a n pero
n es el precio mínimo de cada uno de los
cepillos de la nariz y este comerciante
les 307 pesos por lo tanto vamos a
multiplicarlo por 7 ok esto tiene que
ser más grande o igual tiene que ser
mayor o igual que 1900 si esto es más
grande o igual que en 1900 entonces sí
vamos a aceptar su oferta y bueno para
realizar esta operación que tengo aquí
vamos a traer aquí a mi calculadora ok y
mi calculadora me dice que cuánto es 250
si lo multiplicamos por cuatro pesos ok
ya esto le sumamos
175 que lo vamos a multiplicar por siete
ok y esto va a ser igual a
2.225 de lugo vamos a escribirlo aquí
esto es a 2000 y déjame ponerlo con otro
color
lo voy a poner con este color de aquí
2.225 lo cual en definitiva si es mayor
o igual que 1900 y por lo tanto nos
ponemos bastante contentos porque si nos
conviene o bueno a quienes le conviene
aceptar la oferta de este gran
comerciante por lo tanto vamos a poner
aquí mi respuesta
déjenme tener aquí a la página y vamos a
decir que sí vamos a aceptar la
propuesta y comprobamos una respuesta
perfecto estamos bien